c'est tout simplement le fait que ce
ministère et manuel valls est en train
de s'en rendre compte à ses dépens
ça n'est pas le ministère de la parole
ce n'est pas le mystère de l'image c'est
le mystère de l'action et c'est
effectivement le point faible de manuel
valls
tant qu'on est dans l'image dans le
verbe il est parfait mais aujourd'hui ce
n'est plus ça selon demande c'est des
résultats un an après son arrivée les
chiffres de la délinquance sont
catastrophiques
et là ce qui vient de se passer quand on
a vu l'excès de zèle qui avait été le
sien au moment des manifs des manifs
pour tous
on le voyait passer en revue les les
troupes de deux crs comme s'ils
partaient à la guerre pour aller
affronter à les poussettes et les merdes
et les mères de famille
il est où il est passé où ce manuel
valls aujourd'hui on lui demande d'être
en responsabilité de tirer les
conséquences alors c'est dans soit dans
l'équipe rapprochée de son ministère
c'est le préfet de police s'est lui même
mais ça c'est lui c'est le premier
ministre encore une fois qu'on n'a pas
entendu et c'est le président de la
république qui s'exprimait jeudi je ne
peux pas imaginer que le premier et que
le président la république fasse
l'impasse sur ce sujet d'actes